season three often with shows is where
the characters sort of super evolve you
know you've had the chance to introduce
them and then you had a little bit of
change in conflict but season three it's
almost like all bets are off what
happens in season three with you guys
exactly that yeah we jump ahead there's
a bit of a time cut between season 2 and
season 3 how much it's more than a year
ok ok yeah and we come back to see Billy
and Johanna they've started to practice
together they're together as a couple
and we jump back in when they're about
to go to trial on their first big case
right so it's totally new everything's
totally new for them they're in a
they're in a new a new field and then
they get pulled back to north as you
know as they do and so what does happen
give us the sort of state of mind of
your character going into this season
when you first see them I think there's
a lot of hope yeah and a lot of stress
because everything is you know resting
on this first case which I don't think
this is too big of a spoiler but but
that they struggle with yeah which kind
of throws them into a bit of turmoil
which leads them in a way back to
Millwood where they're confronted with
it with their new case for the season
which is linked to Joanna's past an old
childhood friend of hers and so they're
they're deeply pushed into questions of
who has the right to be a parent and why
and how and and it it is the case that
isn't going to make them a lot of money
and so their relationship is you know
stressed and there's a lot of secrets
and mysteries to be revealed with people
love legal dramas they always have loved
legal dramas but with this sort of
taking something and spreading it out
over the length of time that you guys do
to really get into it what was that like
because it changes everything
where you can't gloss over certain
things like at a really time with the
details of the case right well it's
wonderful because a part of it is
Millwood is a town that is a part of
these people's lives and Billy and
Joanna take on this case in season one
that ultimately destroys the single
industry in that
so that town starts to spiral and there
are a bunch of effects of that spiraling
one being that Billy is ostracized from
a community that adored him another
being that people have stress in their
relationships and thus can't take care
of their children and their children are
pulled away from them and so the
characters have to come in to that and
deal with the effects of something that
we planted in season one and we get to
see that happen and yeah yeah yeah it's
it's really special to be able to take
that time and then look at all the
minutiae all the stuff that happens
around a case all the auxilary things
that happen that fall out because so
often in a legal drama you blow past
that to get to you know the courtrooms
yep this the courtroom scenes are just
one element of a really multifaceted
complicated world and another thing for
that sorry in season three is just that
with Luna who had been accused of murder
in season two she is dealing with the
ramifications of that in season three so
although we've completed that case that
case doesn't ever complete for these
people these cases continue on and
Taylor who was one of the twitching
girls in season one is dealing with the
change in her life what her dreams have
become and what she has lost and how she
has to redefine herself and so that case
that happened two seasons ago and years
ago and our story isn't gone from their
lives and when it comes to these people
who do this you know like there's no
heroes you know I mean like we when it
comes to the law there are ramifications
where if you do the right thing and you
do what is legal in what is right people
may hate you for it yeah because they
the perception is you're a bad person
for even thinking that this should
happen yes although you come from a
different set of values and see things
differently than than they do which is
something that's not really explored
when you put lawyers on television yeah
it's hard to explore that when you're
when you're trying to reach a resolution
inside of an hour but it's this show we
have the benefit of taking that time
taking that that you know whole season
to do a case to tell a story we can
really see the nuance and really see
that it's not black and white it's not
good and evil there's this whole
spectrum that people have all change the
way that you read stories
just real-life stories do you sort of
look at things but you know from
different now that's really I'm
conflicting to even people in your lives
do you see seing things a little bit
differently I think I think as an actor
yeah I've always found it interesting to
look at stories that way to always try
and see as many different point of views
on it because it's just it's just
beneficial when we're working when we're
telling a story to sort of try and be as
nuanced with it yeah but yeah and you
shoot the show where yeah how's that
great yeah I'm from there yeah so it's
great son help when you're so close to
home it's really nice because I know a
lot of people yes I know a lot of your
parents I've been away from the city for
a really long time so in some ways it
kind of there's some parallel things to
what Billy's going through in the
stories and that I'm going back to a
place that has changed and I'm going
back as a person who has changed so it's
playing that and experiencing it
especially with acting you you know when
you're from a smaller sort of part of
you know Canada the idea of being on a
hit show is never in your hometown shows
you have to leave your hometown what was
it like to sort of go back to do
something so great as this where you do
a neat like why did I leave in the first
place yes yeah it's just so good it's so
neat to to film in places where I have
memories of being when I was 14 15 it's
just it's just for me I just get a kick
out of it you know three three seasons
down a row I get a kick out of it every
episode
you